I am an old astronaut Mira cosmonaut
spent about five months off the planet
and now I'm hearing Devils on the planet
bent over the top of this place a couple
thousand times so it's nice to be down
on the earth now and actually putting my
footprint here you know my big love and
life now is the world water and fresh
resources I was out in space looking
down at the planet and you see the great
rivers of the world you know
tigris-euphrates denial the Ganges the
antsy you know defining civilizations
want to go to Mars some day and go to
Mars what's the first thing we're
looking at where are we going to get the
water if you want to survive on Mars
spend five months up closed ecosystem we
had to make our air which actually took
our urine converted it into water and
then we would use that as drinking water
we also use the sweat we condense it
would use that water split the hydrogen
off and we breathe the oxygen from that
h2o so in a very closed ecosystem for
five months failing life-support systems
you figure out very quickly that water
is essential and in that closed
ecosystem you mess up you get the result
very quickly here on earth you know when
looking from space at the earth same
thing closed ecosystem they mess up our
resources down here especially our water
fresh water supplies you know we're
going to pay the consequences
unfortunately on earth it sort of
buffers things out got thousands and
millions of people down here so you
don't get it closed ecosystem three
people you contaminate the water source
and you find out the next day that
you're in trouble so I guess my plane
from here in Devil's World Economic
Forum is that we need to tackle our
fresh water issues around the world and
the developing world get some fresh
drinking water for all the children for
the families that need it in the
developed world taking care of the
resources the beauty of our planet and
keeping the circle of blue as it looks
like from space clean pure and blue for
future generations after our jerry
linenger signing out thanks